and darvish off to a good start as a
padre opponent hitting just 172 against
him three and one 213 era bunch of punch
outs
he has allowed four homers and he can
throw just about anything at any time
three and one a two thirteen era in six
starts
fly ball down the left field line pro
fire going over towards the line to make
the catch in foul ground
so frazier is retired 2-2 to gonzales
and darvish delivers that's a curveball
grounded sharp lead at third gobbled up
by ha sung kim nice play throw across is
firm and in time gonzalez grounds out
and kim continues to flash the leather
one two three top of the first for you
darvish padres are coming up against jt
brubacher 27 year old making his sixth
start he's a homegrown pirate drafted
back in 2015 a sixth rounder makes his
sixth start a lot of strikeouts and very
few walks so he is a strike thrower and
as we mentioned earlier he likes to
throw that slider
and he grounds this one on two hops down
to third base
gonzalez with a bad throw off the glove
of moran and fam will reach through to
the home plate side of first and moran
comes off and glances off the glove so
fam 90 feet away now with two down and
here's eric hosmer
there's the 3-2 pitch fastball strike
three call right on the inner edge
that's nicely done by brubacher
stranding the runner at third through an
inning in san diego the pirates of the
padres scoreless colin moran leading it
off here for the pirates in the second
inning
and that is strike three first strikeout
of the night for you darvish and that'll
bring up hunter owen to make his major
league debut just called up gregory
polanco is placed on the il tom at
second base with two down now and a
one-two
to hunter owen with a swing and a miss
he struck him out
so darvish gets hunter owen to chase his
slider in his first major league at bat
he strikes out don't worry hunter
there's no shame at that and a couple of
k's for darvish here in a scoreless
second andre's lead baseball by far in
stolen bases
he's running here's the pitch bunt
attempt a strike taken throw down and he
is
out
he went off the bag
and jacob stallings throws out will
myers trying to steal
walk his race theo two right in there
with a fastball strike three calls so on
a span of two pitches
uh brubacher now has two outs and the
base is empty
here's the one-two and rolled over on a
breaking ball two easy hops to third
gonzalez on the run gets kim by a step
he motors
then ends the inning so brubacher threw
two scoreless hitless innings
moving on to the third out in san diego
the pirates and the padres are scoreless
ct brubaker the pitcher for the pirates
1-2 from darvish
and that's in there for strike three
third strikeout for you darvish
up the middle
and
tatis with the throw
no wow that was so close
what a spectacular try anyway
but just so fun to watch the range
hats flying yard sale out there moss
flowing
it's unbelievable bottom of the third
inning and victor caratini will lead off
against jt brubacher he's the only padre
to have faced this guy before
this is a fly ball out towards deep
right center field for carratini that
ball is back at the wall that ball is
gone
victor carratini with a home run is
second to padres uniform and the padres
take a one-nothing lead
now the set and the one-two coming and a
swing and a miss darvish dispatched the
pitch
to sema right over the outer edge strike
three call that was beautiful yep that
was wow it's been a great pitch for him
today where he starts it off outside and
just runs it over it faces filled with
friars
well way in on him gonzalez
onto first
and jtb gets out of it they strand three
through three one nothing padres the
pirates have runners in first and second
with one away
and a pop-up
tatisse will make the catch in the
infield fly rule in effect two down 3-2
and a swing and a miss strike shot owen
and owen strikes out for the second time
tonight four strikeouts for you darvish
first and second one out you darvish now
he'll throw the bat
toward the ball
and he's out
trying to bunt foul ball now you got
runners still on first and second and
you got no it's great
the pitch
swing and a miss he chased the slider
well out of the zone and the yelling end
so one hit an error and two left the
padres have left on six we'll go to the
fifth we head here to the top of the
fifth inning for you darvish
in there for strike three that is
strikeout number five for you darvish
and a good start to the fifth inning
swinging a miss and brubacher down by
way of the k for the second time tonight
that is six strikeouts now for you
darvish
that's strike three four consecutive k's
for you darvish
we are midway at petco and you is
dealing again padres won pirates nothing
audrey's in action here with will myers
coming to the plate
lined into the left field of basement
tatis from third will put the padres on
top two to nothing an rbi single for
willmeyer still just a two-nothing game
in the fifth inning here's the o2
swing at a miss struck about on that
slider right over the outer edge
and brubacher does it he strikes out kim
pandres get a run on two hits they
strand two third time around reynolds oh
for two in the pitch
swinging a fly ball to left deep pro far
back warning track and there it goes
home run for brian reynolds
and he gets one back for the bucks on
his third home run of the year 2-1 san
diego
[Applause]
line drive to center field by kai tom
and it is going to be caught
by tommy pham but it ties the game
heck giving it back for the rookie the
pirates have runners yet first and
second with two down and into the game
is craig stamen he's a workhorse 13th
game for craig opponents hitting 211.
here's the pitch to newman and a ground
ball to third base kim backs up on it he
will put it in the glove now across the
diamond his throw is just in time to get
newman and in the inning second and
third with nobody out here in the sixth
inning for the padres keep giving the
padres extra outs here's the pitch
swing and a miss he struck him out on
that changeup down and away boy it can
be filthy
second and third one out and jake
cronenworth now the infield in
kronerworth to right fail the base hit
from third caratini scores here comes
grisham here comes the throw it'll be
late padres take a 4-2 lead
jake cronenworth driving in a pair
he's got a two run lead here and his
number is his 15th game more strikeouts
and then he's pitched
gonzalez strikes out first strikeout for
pagan one down here in the eighth
not this time he strikes out looking
back-to-back case for begone two down in
the eighth inning
that is caught at first base by hosmer
on the line drive after seven and a half
padres four pirates two mark melanson
enters his 14th game he has ten for ten
in save opportunities pirates will bring
the tying run to the plate
runner goes and a ground ball to third
base and comes hassan kim
that is your ball game no they pulled
him
hosmer came off the bag
and they are going to get together to
their credit and check it out we got out
we got the end of the ball game padres
win